by the way how great was that alyssa
milano thing with the with the police
did you catch that i didn't catch it oh
[Music]
yeah she she called the police on a kid
using an air gun
uh because he looked suspicious in the
neighborhood he was wearing all black
and
it's just this whole defund the police
and then she calls the police when she
sees a teenager
shooting at a squirrel oh wow that is
gorgeous it's too perfect oh it's that's
what you call poetic justice
i mean yes wow i mean
alyssa milano i don't know about you but
she's my president
well it's weird to have jerked off to a
a presidential candidate i guess but
obama was sexy
but yeah yeah i mean it's insane there
it is i mean it's just too
perfect whenever the person railing
against something
is that thing isn't that always the way
absolutely it goes that way with
sexuality it goes that way with politics
it goes that way
with anything it's called shakespeare
had a little expression for i think it
was called
thou doth protest too much there it is
we've all seen
the homophobic pastor who gets caught
with a couple of hotties under his desk
i mean it's uh it's it's as old as time
a tale is old as time
now let me ask you a question because
the left always accuses the right
i call them the fan base because that's
really what they are now it's not really
a body politic it's more of a fan base
i mean because you know i mean
politicians are like bands now
all right you know so it's like they're
just following him like a band so do you
think because
the left fan base always accuses the
right fan base of being [ __ ] stupid
but what they fail to realize is they've
made uh the former child star of
who's the boss sort of one of their main
spokespersons who they follow
do you think that they're all [ __ ]
stupid are we all just [ __ ] stupid at
this point
here's what i think and this is why i
stay out of the whole political thing i
don't read
i don't learn anything because everybody
just gets so deep into their side
it's like capture the flag they just
want to win so bad they're not even
looking at what's going on
it feels like two divorced parents
trying to beat each other
and they're not taking care of their
sick kids we're going hey mom i'm
coughing up blood here she's going hold
on your dad [ __ ] a porn star now he's
tweeting about it i don't have time for
you
i like that analogy it's true yeah the
kids are yeah we're just left in front
of the tv
they just handed us a tablet like
[Laughter]
exactly you ever go to dinner with your
friends who have kids and like
you're always like you're thinking like
oh my god these kids are gonna be
jumping all over the seats they're gonna
because that's how we were we were kids
we were climbing all over the streets
yanking on our dad's dicks you know
throwing spare ribs at each other
chinese restaurants or whatever because
we're so bored
but now you just hand the kid to tablet
and i mean they all become like
manchurian candidates they just kind of
like [ __ ]
they're quiet and quieter than a monk i
mean i know
well it's one of those weird things
where you're like oh this is probably
bad for the kid but
[ __ ] i got to eat this wonton in peace
you [ __ ] dweeb
shut up you know so it's that weird
quick fix
and i get it i'm not a parent but i do
love when parents do it
yeah it's like yeah i'm trying to [ __ ]
this girl you know behind his mom's back
let me just hand him a tablet he won't
remember any of this
because he was [ __ ] like the
neuralizer for mib he just had about
angry birds
yeah yeah so we got some stories i mean
you came in with a banger i didn't even
have that
on the list for today's stories i mean
you came in with a banger
you know that that's exactly what you
would you would expect from our
reporters in the field because right now
you're on the field from a park bench
i assume uh i assume from a safe
neighborhood right
well it was i'm in the west village
which uh i used to be
in like a nice white haven now it's uh
it's grand theft auto out here i got i
got hobos hitting me up and
uh it's it's crazy and my park bench has
been taken up
this used to be a nice area yeah yeah
i mean it's during the day though you
can still get look new york is
bad right now uh
if you during the day but at night if
you love heroin it's a great place no
i'm still on oxycontin but yeah yeah
it's it's wild there's needles
everywhere there's barrel fires
it's that thing where i'm hearing weird
howling at night from hobos like
you know like you know that [ __ ] you're
trying to you're trying to watch
uh the social dilemma and all you hear
is like [ __ ] you
jesus government f word n-word you're
like god damn
yeah what are you doing i'm trying to
listen to tim ferriss over here
yeah yeah that's well you know
i'm watching cuties leave me alone he's
got a lot of good tips
tim ferriss yeah
yeah i mean the smaller the guy the
bigger the ambition that's just true i
mean it's just always what it is
kevin hart yeah um but uh
i always wondered like those guys like
gary vee like what are they doing right
now because
you can't really put up a clip you know
going hey just grind it out right now
you know
[ __ ] give up your day job and go
start a business you can't put those
you can't put those up now when people
are looking for you know
i mean this is how you know the economy
is bad when bus boys are white again
[Laughter]
it's true it's funny you always say this
about how we just keep going back
to like what we used to do everything's
just a full circle
and uh bus boys are honkeys
um like even facebook just feels like a
small town
you know you go on facebook and you're
like oh you guys are just in this bubble
this is how the civil war started you're
not getting out and talking to anybody
you're not discussing anything with
anybody different and you're just in a
small town you've you've decided who you
want to be in that town
you you say your little quotes and quips
and you like everything and then you
move on and you
it's it's crazy we just keep going back
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild